I love you way too awesome we can fight
this you're right
the cancer is only my liver lungs
prostate and brain all things I can live
without what if I told you we can make
you better you're a fighter we can give
you abilities most men only dream of
make you a superhero would you just
promise you'll do right by me so I can
do right by someone else and please
don't make the supersuit green or
animated one thing that never survives
this place it's a sense of humor we'll
see about that posh spice oh come on you
know leave me all alone here with less
angry Rosie O'Donnell I wanna thank your
mother for what
[Music]
yay you may be wondering why the red
suit well that's so bad guys can't see
me bleed this guy's got the right idea
he wore the brown pants daddy needs to
express some rage
Oh [ __ ] you are hard to look at
like a testicle with teeth you look like
Freddy Krueger face-fucked a
topographical map of Utah
exactly oh I'm touching myself tonight
[Music]
you look like an avocado had sex with an
older avocado thank you
hey youtubers is Charlie so fresh red
band chimichangas this is gonna be a
breakdown to that and at the end of the
video I'll announce the winners from the
giveaway so here we go
so yeah everybody cried taco tears of
joy this is pretty much the footage they
showed off a comic-con just a little
more polished and they added a couple of
music tracks most of the story that they
tell in it is chronological Wade Wilson
and his girlfriend Vanessa Carlysle
finding out that he has like super
cancer all over his body so he enters
the Weapon X program now in the comics
he ends up washing out of that into
doctor kill brews lab I don't know that
the movie is doing doctor kill brew so
they might do this as like some sort of
offshoot of Weapon X the place they're
willing him into here looks a lot like
the Weapon X facility from Wolverine
Origins so we'll see how the movie deals
with it it's still true to the origin
story they basically abuse the crap out
of everybody that they bring in here
they they perform kind of crazy
experiments on them Gina Carano as I
said before is playing angel dust now in
the comics she's one of the Chicago
Morlocks so this film looks like it's
making her a little bit more sinister
she's not quite so hardcore whenever she
shows up in that Morlocks storyline and
she's actually she's created by geoff
johns of the DC universe which i think
is kind of funny if he didn't catch it
he takes a big swipe at Green Lantern
when they're willing him in he's like
just don't make the suit green or
animated it's just in keeping with the
grand tradition of Deadpool making fun
of everything Ryan Reynolds did the
exact same thing when they posted the
teaser trailer he just he made fun of
Wolverine Origins for sewing his mouth
shut
this is ed skrein playing Ajax now in
the comics like he looks way more hulked
out but he gets modified too he's
wearing a lab coat so what they might
have done with the movie is just
combined his character with doctor
Killebrew and then we jumped forward to
the bridge scene this is right out of
that test footage that leaked before
Comic Con 2014 it looks like they reshot
some of it and they just they polished
it up we get the stand off some classic
wisecracking standard badassery all
those guys poop their pants thank you
for wearing brown now we don't see the
healing factor but his healing factor is
a little bit different from Wolverines
in the comics he's is much more
instantaneous and it's the reason why
they can't fix his brain like in the
comics Deadpool is slightly insane
because his brain would regenerate
instantly they can't fix it and medicine
doesn't work on him so he is permanently
nuts the body count Rises
is this is the first shot at Wiesel it
looks like he's gonna be a relatively
good character in this film in the
comics is a little more ambiguous he's a
bit more of a dirtbag gina carano just
given him the business this looks like
his escape from the Weapon X program or
dr. kill bruised lap whatever they're
gonna end up calling it you can see that
his face isn't like completely messed up
yet it's kind of hard to see here but we
actually see what Stanley's cameo is he
is the MC inside this strip club that
they're in holla and if you were his age
that would probably be a pretty badass
job to have too we should all be so
lucky to spend our twilight years like
that here's another shot of copycat
probably about as naked as you're gonna
see Morena Baccarin this year and here
we get our big chrome [ __ ] gobbler
Colossus
now he's being played by a different
character and if you see this
behind-the-scenes image you can see that
I think it's just to make him like way
way taller Daniel Cudmore played the
character in the x-men films
this is negasonic teenage witch she's
gonna be something of a sidekick to
Deadpool in the movie but she might show
up with Colossus or help deadpool find
him just because they're both x-men
characters she's right out of Emma Frost
school she was also a member of the
Hellfire Club this is blind al big big
character in Deadpool's history a lot of
rumors about who she might be they've
wrecked conned her past several times
because of all the changes they made to
Marvel Comics originally she was
supposed to be the very first black
widow before natasha romanoff took the
mantle but Marvel Comics has changed
some of that stuff she's like this
mystery character that Deadpool is
ordered to hunt down but he also wants
to protect so he like she's kind of like
his captive but it's a weird benevolent
situation where she ends up being kind
of a mother to him very messed up but
very cool and here we just get like the
montage of weasel making fun of
Deadpool's face he look like an avocado
had sex with an older avocado Deadpool
vs Ajax this is obviously much later in
the film after he's taken on the persona
it looks like he's gone rogue and
they're trying to bring him back into
the program and boom that's it so
Deadpool the movie for those that are
wondering is coming out in February next
year so we actually we don't even have
to wait that long it's not gonna be like
summer it's not gonna be a full year we
don't know if Ryan Reynolds has signed a
contract to do multiple films because if
this is successful of course they're
gonna do a sequel but everybody that's
ever worked on the comic Rob Liefeld the
create
the character they're all saying really
awesome things about the movie a lot of
people have seen that the work prints of
the film they're saying it's badass so
I'm really excited and honestly this
gets me pumped up I feel like this is
just like the next step in like you know
a Marvel character even even though it's
a Fox film being done in a really crazy
gratuitous way people got really excited
when daredevil came out just because it
was so much more hardcore than like the
network Marvel shows I feel like this is
the next step for the movies
congratulations to the Deadpool giveaway
winners there's actually two John Norris
and Kurosaki Ichigo you guys both win
$20 Amazon gift cards just message me on
my channel so I can get your contact
info I think my next Deadpool video will
just be like a Q&A so I can just do a
catch-all for all the questions that you
guys have about the movie because I
promise to do that Hawkman and Vandal
Savage video that'll probably be next
and then I'll do the Q&A after that just
to give people time to find this video
so let me know what do you guys think
about the film after this and if you
have to see this in Hall H let me know
what you thought about that experience
compared to sing it now like I said
really like there's not a lot different
about the footage it's the same basic
thing they just they made it look a
little bit shinier so if you should
haven't seen it I just did a fantastic
for Deadpool video you can click here to
watch that learn all about the ultimate
origin story and some of the x-men
crossover stuff that they're working on
for down the road and you can click here
to learn all about Deadpool sidekicks in
the movie thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you